great to be here and looking forward to
a fun fun conversation into the plan to
see some familiar faces
folks like Mitch caper who was actually
the original risk outside investment
role networks back in 1995 so other
folks here a big who was spoke earlier
and see Tom admits be hopping around out
here somewhere so it's great to decorate
did see some old friends meet some new
of fellow loves as well
so I'm gonna ask you a quick summary of
who I am in my mind my background I grew
up in New York I started at the L 35
years ago which remember that scares me
but it's mathematically correct I did my
first company started which company
while I was at Yale the fall of 81 I
worked for ID on this summer the IBM PC
came out and was a great place right
that's right climb another thing started
a company the baking's to the idea pcs
there work on them in the fall of my
junior year summer off and and finish
the games and distributed nationally a
couple of classmates learned a bunch
about the business and it's fun doing it
it was compared favorably there was
summer job but it was not going to be
that company was not going to be the
rocket ship for many many reasons that I
figure there's a lot I had to learn and
share incorrect I finished in 83 with a
BS in CS and a necessary economics so I
kind of have a technical that passes for
a business background coming out of out
of Yale and then it's been 10 years at
distance acqua company called Microsoft
and I remember my mom was from
California she's delicious
looma so what we were living in Europe
at the time and when I first talked
about moving west
I remember explaining to her that this
little company about 250 people and I
was job and I could afford to take a
risk if it didn't work out I'd do
something else
and so I know that you all grow up in a
world where notion of Microsoft being a
twisted place to go is is kind of a
crazy idea but 31 years ago that was the
those which were bought it not in the
libertage or not people are involved
with technology and I had a fantastic
take you right there learn a ton then it
started with networks 20 years ago
should incorporate in February of
nineteen forces just delivered four
years ago and had a great ride which
I'll talk a little about them got back
on the worst about two years ago so and
you tell them talk fast so after that
North you 90 seconds so the first five
years of several networks later was a
rocket ship ride we introduced the
Internet's first streaming audio system
and then one of the first video systems
we were both super products and
technology and it was a phenomenal
growth curve one point leading 40 to the
30 to 65 one 30 to 40 plus or minus 240
is interesting though because the first
half of that year we often did 130 so we
were doubling every year
and then the second half that year we
could see things were changing
last week we talked about getting IDL
right around the time the tech bubble
burst I remember that time very vividly
as you could imagine we also were hit by
a telecom bubble burst in which we saw a
lot of software to the telecom roads and
also Microsoft
we're starting to violate antitrust laws
now they competed with us
and why we ended up settling with them
very favorably some years later for
about three-quarters of billion dollars
the short-term impact was quite negative
as you see there on our revenues and
some other pieces as well so we had to
reinvent the company and I did some time
I won't talk about the details of every
invention but I will show you the
results we continue to three years we
revitalize the company reinvigorated
growth and got over half a million
dollars in revenue by 2008 which of
course was from the Great Recession hit
who's actually a few different things
happened at that time after writing
broke about 16 years I had a kid later
in life they're all great now but I
wanted to shift gears variety of reasons
I have twins they're not seven and a
half and almost four year old so I after
16 years I stepped back from day to day
the fire my heart my successor
unfortunately Mike's so that was a not
the ideal way to creep down in the
company about two years ago and this
spring of 2012 the board came to me and
asked if I was there I'd stayed on the
board but consider getting more involved
and in the July 2012 so the lesson two
years ago I got back involved initially
just for a couple of months this or a
seed
kind of what we had and come up with
some thoughts like where we go next and
ended up presenting to the board a
couple months in the team kind of thing
our Brewers should go and about that
today and sort of the pivot that you're
frankly right now in the middle of as I
talk to you today so in this is from
literally this text from slides from
early September of 2012 ready to back
about two months we basically made the
first macro decision which is you have
to decide are you do you do one thing
when you have multiple things you do and
we decided to radically decentralized
the company at that time I focus on four
things one would Exeter be spun off our
staking the wrap to the music service
you know my 45% of it as we did at the
time and then we have three other
divisions that we ended up deciding the
best thing to do is to create optimal
intent technology product go to market
business and sales strategies preach to
them so we decentralize the company
quite significantly at the time we
decided to run each business in an
independent way and would allocate
resources based on the combination of
the prospects if I would have a success
and and actually the results achieved
and then we ended up closing down the
amount or two cases shutting down a few
cases were integrating into some of the
mothership businesses the rest of what
we're doing so we've refocused the
company secretly and then we
decentralized so no more central
Technology Group no more central
marketing group and every 95 percent of
the staff of the company you work for or
with seconded to one of the offering
visions so we didn't that's that's half
of it then you actually have to have
strategy to reach to businesses so for
the three main businesses we created the
strategies to take the route of a player
which was amazing they need to be very
popular soft we'll talk with a PC but
had very little presence on mobile
devices on the cloud on televisions and
grow very broadly cross-platform with
that we took our character services
visit the SAS business and decided hey
characters are good at selling some
stuff but they're really bad is on
consumer products
so let's move into a different model
around that and create product services
that we will market ourselves in
partnership with characters I mean
alcohol that model carrot or character
table over the top but at the time it
was just hey we've got it
we had this bubbly create products that
are getting into market we've got a
changeover doing business we have a game
to business with us cause division will
be focused on my new innovations around
social casino internet business so one
cocktail today eighteen months later the
strategy Ron is fundamentally the
strategy set motion in the quality 2012
which i think is a good thing there's
also time we'll know for sure but we
didn't didn't to keep iterating we treat
direction set sail the first sailing
products they have an incubation period
of gestation query takes time to build
time when we can't have a baby the month
kind of thing so we ended up some of the
needs new products change the customer a
player is done these will clear cloud
we've renamed the SAS division mobile
entertainment to focus on the kinds of
products and services creating the
community the first product integration
carriers with this directive consumer is
called listen it's a directive of summer
advance bring back some product or
service and then we did a series of
products and games in a period of time I
won't talk much about the issues that's
how phenomenal guy to run that division
so I looked how we're doing today
there's a lot of good news and admission
not so good news is you'd imagine this
kind of situation first if you think it
is we'll each integrate products again
companies like ours products are the
lifeblood of the company in a great
product you know in the short term you
can kind of Street private long term
nothing else matters
so revitalize the product culture the
combination of bringing the new people
in a few cases brings and people back in
cases promoting it increases the
possibilities of some of the people that
I see but also with some of our
initiatives where we really wanted to be
first to market well we do have some
competitive advantages is the first
market much better than chasing somebody
else's clothing somebody else if you're
super being and you have a distant
platform like Amazon Amazon to be best
FB for us going into selling makeup
online they've got a huge customer base
they could leverage that well we have
decent install basically things like the
road layer and our 80 million customers
that around the world that are
subscribers to bring back home services
with carriers we don't think those
eventually was so big that they
substitutes were that not being first
mover obviously important so we wanted
to have and grow through their first
mover in those initiatives and our
products are resonating with consumers
just to touch not a few of them a real
player cloud is probably the single most
important issue of the company I'm kind
of curious in this group raise your hand
if the last year you used you to row
player cloud or a player on one of your
devices we've got a few hands we got
more work to do obviously well the good
news is we have the two million
registered users in six months which
we're very excited about
it's really quite as a global quick
right about half of that's in the US and
we are now on about 10 different devices
every kind of PC you know back
the web device iPhone and variable
tablets and phones three or four teeth
from TV devices Roku chromecast we just
recently shipped on the amazon firetv
product the reviews have been terrific
both Mossberg you know famously tough on
products were said bro clever clatters
well-designed make storing and sharing
videos easily across different devices
we have a technology called short play
that make sure the video you upload can
play anywhere and that's working well so
we're off the races with this product
we've a lot of work to do we have to
increase its morality which is a bit
over we've laid the foundation for that
but he never protects kick in you've got
to give it some scale or gonna have that
we have to keep innovating with Road
Apple think we want to do in the next
year we're going to keep putting
iterations out one of the things to be
changed about the company as we move to
basically from waterfall type software
evelopment to pretty much full scrum and
everything we do so we iterate and are
getting our new products out very fast
to go product with this magnitude out in
a year or basically from when we get the
start button and launch them ever
October last year we super happened with
how fast it went but we have to keep
moving fast it's a market they're very
competitive is is everywhere on vecinos
the second product which just went to
the US last month is called listen if
you're on t-mobile it's available now
downloaded try check it out into next
generation ring back home product we
it's frankly bring back some barely
touches the scratch the surface of what
it is we we have this good relationship
with carriers where we can insert things
in the call path so when you call me
you'll necessarily just feel a ring ring
you hear what I want you to hear which
could be music it could be ham in a
meeting
call me back I'll call you back in an
hour hey I'm in a meeting send me a text
you know it could be you know
if your girlfriend calls to be you know
hey would you pick up a loaf of bread
I forgot you you know you can you can
put whatever you want in that call pal
in music audio notification messages etc
and we're just building that out with a
really good apps for smartphones we have
both iPhone and Android versions of
those apps we market the service
ourselves there was a great discussion
of a couple sessions to go on do how to
do SCM and directly direct to a user
consumer marketing carriers typically
aren't good at that they have some
structural advantages they have the
billing relationship with you which we
leverage the phone number through the
leverage of a point of sale distribution
which we leverage but the in terms of
really getting out there being scrappy
and creative in marketing all the
different touch points that consumers
typically carriers don't have that MA
and that skill set so the fact that we
are not taking this on ourselves sets us
up to be successful the early days yet
but I feel good about the checklist on
wall so the market the UK we're rolling
out to the carrier's around the world
the knowledge good news the first point
is that the turnaround is going to take
longer than we thought we did an
earnings call yesterday and you sort of
said as much they were history we sort
of said as much that it's gonna take a
couple of quarters longer than we wanted
it to that's a combination of sort of
the physics of these things related for
that is it's going to have cost a little
more that we thought now in hindsight
both those things are predictable if
you've ever been involved in ability
products going to businesses things
always take longer than a finite point I
have to differentiate one of the things
in this kind of role between signal and
noise which is to say women delay is a
one-time offset versus is a structural
problem like you're not building the
stock we're past not work you're not
closing sales fast enough and one of the
things that bigger to teach
entrepreneurs is weak to signal check or
pattern match the difference between
something that's moving more slowly
because of one-time offsets versus
something's moving more slowly because
of the more structural
fundamental issue and I feel good that
fun being picture we're on the right
track of both these initiatives as well
as other initiatives at used to time I'm
not touching on today but we got a lot
of work to prove them so to sum up and I
will take questions as long as time
permits I identify a few lessons that
I've learned from the 20 years of
running real were temporally the 30
years since leaving Yale or the 33 years
that started my first company first is
that person startups are hard they're
not for the faint of heart
they're they're not trivial and they
have a very statistically low success
rate but that doesn't mean that they're
not worth doing because they can be very
rewarding in all kinds of ways
psychologically the sense of building
something that sense of camaraderie that
comes from teamwork together a feeling
of empowerment the feeling would make a
difference in the world all that stuff
remarkable independent of in any
financial benefits which can also come
pivoting and turnarounds are also hard
it's hard to say which is which is
easier which is harder realnetworks was
an example company that we hit on our
first iteration so we didn't have the
slog that a lot of startups have but if
you look at them across the basic
startups you know a lot of them you know
Moneo twitter is a great example of a
company that was basically a failed
company that pivoted to a to a different
more successful model there's the lot of
time people started something takes time
then they iterate so I would say both
are hard and not sure one part than the
other the one thing about a turnaround
or a pivot it's little harder is you
have a higher risk of distractions
because you've got all this legacy stuff
around you that's probably the biggest
difference I would say I've said that
both of them require some core
attributes and the five that identified
that I think are central to any big
success are at least one great
and that is to say you can have more
than one great idea but if it was your
great ideas you're not gonna be any
success and and it's it's a very
judgmental thing to say sometimes you
know something is a good idea in
creative theory but a bad idea in
practice if something sounds good if
something is a great idea but someone
else beat you to the punch so but a
great idea is this essential foundation
second obviously you've got to have
massive passion for it one of the things
that I would look for when I do angel
nesting I'm less active now I just do a
few things here but when I was stepping
away from earning real I was more active
I became a venture partner at Excel
where the VC firm that that really work
with those guys they're super smart to a
person one of the things though that
they always look before an island the
floor was just past some people that you
know have that run through wall passion
about what they're doing and that just
did one individual but the team of
leaders that are said to him and the
culture their company the third thing
which is different than passion although
often cartilage but not always is
persistence in the face of setbacks I
met some passionate people that just
really weren't persistent they go
they're passionate but when they hit a
wall that bounce off the wall they want
a different direction sometimes you got
to really figure out key where's the
piece in that wall that I can break
through somebody's gotta go around the
wall so there's got to go over it or
under it but a lot of times I've found
that what differentiates successful
entrepreneurs from unsuccessful
isn't the passion it's the persistence
in the face of passion and the face of
existence and maintaining that
persistence and obviously maintained the
passion that drove you there the fourth
point I would say is the resources to
enable you to maintain the persistence
and that's obviously not doesn't mean
you have to have a mass amount of money
in fact I think one of the things that
could happen in bubble environments as
companies can you get over capitalized
by that I mean they get sloppy and they
lose their discipline and lose their
focus and they are not focusing on the
key metrics of what is going to drive
their business to be successful so I
think you have but you have to have
adequate resources so that you can't
cysts and maybe you have to hunker down
and maybe make a team smaller in the
face of resistance but you gotta still
have the ability to get through the
chasm and get to the other side and the
fifth point that I make is teamwork and
collaboration which is these are
buzzwords in a way but they're obviously
stunningly important
I talked to Bing after after his session
and I've heard him say was I believe he
said you ourselves on the slides I mean
I've talked about it and one of the
things he thinks it's characteristics of
yellow alums is a orientation towards
collaboration and teamwork and whether
it's a private part of the educational
process going through whether it's self
selection on the front of the funnel I
don't know if I narrowly say that I see
that as like a black-and-white attribute
of every entrepreneur I've met or DL
grads that have worked Ruth in business
but it certainly is something that I
think could be undervalued when you get
people who are used to super high
achievement you know it place like Yale
or Stanford or any of these super
difficult to get into schools you
typically get in there on the base of
individual achievement but commercial
success and tease is almost always
dominant leader in my team's success and
so I'd look to recruit interview people
you know if somebody's the only person
person pronoun the users eye and they
lose we that's a red flag for me and I'm
doing vetting and records checking you
know we if we hear that you know someone
who's really smart but they just work
well with other people that's almost
always a a red flag that will slow them
down or even trending higher so I would
say that this set of attributes I think
our core a success pietà a startup
success being an intrapreneur success or
a pivot or a turnaround so with that I
hope you found that a reasonable summary
of 35 years of life experience 20 years
in real networks and happy to take
questions as time permits
so our codec for those that didn't live
this world was one of the width we
bootstrapped because there were no good
ways to stream audio at modem bit rates
in the very beginning period of time so
there was a it was a need to invent
technology we recognized in the long
term once the minute industry grew that
would stabilize us so what ended up
happening more to decouple our front end
in our back room businesses was the was
to be tranquil it was the rise of
standardization the MPEG in the east up
to 64 standards that and second the fact
that Microsoft when they were compete
with us when two computer manufacturers
who went to content companies and paid
them not to use our technology and to
only use their technology so there was
sort of a forced decoupling through
checkbook diplomacy would say so so in
that context there was an inevitability
of the decoupling and some market things
to stop the accelerated it the only
market where clones of the real
technology had a specific effect on us
of note where China and weirdly enough
that cut a few different ways the
disadvantage is people have stolen our
code they didn't bother like doing a
clean one condition they just literally
stole our code we proven in courts in
China that it's our code and the penalty
is like 19 cents or something so it has
not been an effective way for us to to
be back consumer companies that take our
software put it old wine in new bottles
or put our code in a new vessel and sell
it as their honor it has helped us
however by making our software our codec
super prevalent in China the real format
in terms of market share in China is the
number one market in terms of market
share we have in the world today so when
we do deals with legitimate companies
like chipset manufacturers we are they
little legitimate source for them
licensing so we have a very nice
licensing technology licensing revenue
into Cotulla attracts devices mobile
phones etcetera principally in China
because of that piracy so it kind of cut
both ways but otherwise what happened
the rest of world was more about those
other factors the next question I'll try
to make it so long the third row there
yeah
well I would say a few things if I had
not taken time away it would have been
harder and after 15 16 years when I
stepped away it helped me a few in a few
ways or rekindled my passion one I just
against to catch my breath and have a
different work-life balance and you have
when you're running a company a second I
be able to spend time learning about
things through the desert so startups I
invested in through being a venture
partner and Excel seeing how the world
had changed so my view of the world was
not simply a incremental extrapolation
what I'd see before it was very
different so when the board asked me to
come back in 20 months ago I had a very
different point of view about what
needed to be done and therefore when I
approached people both summing the
company some who had left the company
who had brought back in and some new to
the company it was kind of a a it's a
little bit like you know an old house
used to live in you come back that you
want to renovate it you sort of know
what you liked about the house you know
how beautiful the views were you also
know where the termites were you know
with you know you haven't have a window
that was never quite right cement will
just knock it out start over again so
you have you have knowledge of what was
there and kind of why why it might not
be quite right so it's a combination of
rekindled passion new people that we
brought in who have a new passion in
some cases people who came back who had
a simpler type Derby to me where they
left did other stuff
and we're able to have a respect around
it and then some some people that have
been longtime people and most of their
past that comes from the fact that
they're doing bigger jobs our general
counsel for instance a 13 year real
leather and wine 8gc he was one tear
down that when I came back and he's
terrific and it's his first time being a
GC so he has not been a general counsel
for 13 years she's been a general
counsel for a year and a half so that he
is passionate because he's doing
something new yeah questioning the
second row
resistance
well I think it's a trade-off I think
you sort of have to you have to approach
these things with almost not as gates of
training but the dichotomous view which
is to say your default has to be you
know for assistance and energetic focus
on how are we going to achieve what we
set out to achieve and then you have to
have an opportunity ability to step back
and say hey are we not achievement or
wanted because it's not going to happen
are we not even out because you know
we're to achieving four out of the six
things we have to do and we have to fix
the other two and then being being
objective about whether the two that you
that are not happening are easily
fixable or hard to fix and if those two
that aren't going right if you have a
substitute or strategy for it you fix
one of them and then you can still be
successful so it's a combination of you
really have to bring that that that
persistence to the to the table almost
all the time but then you have to have a
willingness to step back periodically
Andy Grove the former CEO of Intel where
a few books about maddux and we call
these things strategic inflection points
which is where you have to be willing to
step back and say is this going the
right is the world changing what do we
do and I recommend his books as great
examples of two or three different books
you just google that phrase and there
are one or two books with that concept
figures are prominently there write
several good ones those are among the
best - so it's it's more honor than
science but there is a you can't be
methodical in stepping back and forth
through self to step back you know every
three months or something that's how the
whole word is a she's deaf back which is
if selectively pick areas where there's
reasonable to double-check and you can
you do that vigorously but typically
only for a short period of time yeah
yeah Greenspan's fine here
Tatia overlay and mark
well there's no way the choice to be a
that's one of the part more of than
science things so how do you actually
connect opportunities for innovation
with understanding or a market your
element I mean it's you can quote great
Wayne Gretzky's all you want you know
the famous quoted you know and a white
lights much better than anyone else
which is well I don't go over the puck
is I go to the puck is going so you can
say hey the answer is you go where the
puck was going but you'd only know in
hindsight whether you went where the
puck was really going or whether you
went where you thought the puck should
have gone but it didn't end up going
that way I always tell people one of one
of the things too that I was emphasizes
the role that timing plays in these
market developments so and so it you
could say that you said to the other
saying luck of timing when we launch to
a lot of in April of 95 was
fantastically lucky timing because
people were just starting to see the
commercial Internet as a possibility so
if we want some two years later maybe
video later certainly three years later
we wouldn't have been first and as a
start-up if you're not first its odds
are good you're not going to be relevant
you're not gonna have the kind of rocket
ship ride that we have so I would say
that the X Factor that often determines
the difference between you've got the
right of their section point between
technology and market and you don't is
the timing of when you bring that
product to market I know there's been a
lot of talk in the mobile er about MVPs
Minimum Viable products as a way of
probing test
I'm not a pure believer in MVPs I'm a
selectable uber MVP sometimes MVP that
are crap experiences give you a false
negative on idea and sometimes if you if
you rush
you don't implement it in a way that's
great you can you can hit that you know
if you look it you know take something
like it's a massive obviously financial
success from an investor standpoint
what's out great
what's Apple is an example of a product
that did something in a way that it was
very obvious to do was just use IP as a
means of creating a network effect
around messaging and drive it up to
massive scale there were a dozen
companies maybe 50 company maybe a
thousand companies they were trying to
something and messaging whatsapp did a
better job than just about any startup
in making the experience so good and
making the use of it so friction-free it
just kind of grew and grew grew and grew
I had let the natural morality of that
mob that take off but but the the other
49 that didn't become what saps and you
know and the other 43 that didn't become
much of anything at all only come only
got one or two things wrong but maybe
they didn't have the reliability of
revenue boo you I was too hard to use
maybe their pricing model is wrong but
you know these markets are sort of
Darwinian you know when I deal like that
which is very horizontal it's very
unlikely that they'll be they'll be more
than a small fraction of people would
enter that would get enough for those
pieces right and those just the other
ones that had the right idea just won't
hit it quite right so there's still one
final question yeah any spirit of
educators not here any women who haven't
asked questions you'd like to I can't
see gender from that okay great
how did I know that was the right time
please Microsoft that's an excellent
question of course they didn't but I
knew that it was the right time for me
I've been at Microsoft at the time
almost ten years and I had a fantastic
ride when I got there is about 250
people as I mentioned 50 million in
revenue when I left it was thousands of
employees and it was hits close to 10
years and I started figured in my head
and doctoring that aware that after a
while something becomes what you're
doing with your life
unless you make a change and I didn't
have any financial impediments threw at
me from making a change my health was
good I didn't have kids my parents house
was good I didn't have any of the things
that might prevent you from plunging all
into a startup I didn't know that the
internet was coming in fact that when I
first started longer story at the time
for today but I was equally focused on
the dial-up connectivity world that used
something about and I and also the world
of interactive television and I spent
time about six months probably ginger so
I was hopeful that it was a sea change
but I didn't know the aha moment for me
actually came Memorial Day weekend 19
1993 when I went to Electronic Frontier
Foundation board meeting in Austin Texas
Mitch kapor who's a good friend of mine
invited me to it and a guy I'm on the
board named Dave Farber who truly is one
of the fathers of the Internet gathered
us all around the table I said have you
ever seen this mosaic thing I had not it
was an early version of the NCSA mosaic
web browser that Marc Andreessen and his
band of young Pirates at the University
of Illinois champaign-urbana were
working on that had just been released
into the wild it was very simple very
primitive the best thing that I had on
topic we grounded windows but also had
been Macs and had a
four images in it and so literally upon
seeing that was like wow we could do the
same thing for audio and video that that
thing does for images and text we could
have me something amazing and so it was
really I was at the right place at the
right time it was after I had basically
left Microsoft about three months after
took a couple months traveling abroad
came back and through a brilliant friend
who had you know very creative group of
people you know nonprofit context that I
discovered the product commercial
Internet
so again if you always have to choose
between being lucky and good pick lucky
every time